[Music]
Disney Channel has given lots of amazing
family friendly entertainment but things
on the inside aren't always so happy
stay tuned to find out which star serves
time in prison for a major crime before
he was on the Disney Channel
do you love knowing all the cool facts
and dark secrets about Disney's don't
forget to subscribe to the things not so
best friends Hannah Montana is one of
the most beloved Disney Channel shows of
all time it stars Miley Cyrus as a pop
star Hannah Montana who tries to keep
her famous identity a secret Miley's
best friend on the show was Lily who was
played by Emily Osment their
relationship on the show was totally
friendship goals but apparently they
were just really good actors for most of
the show's run they hated each other
they fought all the time in fact Miley I
said she didn't think that they could
ever be friends Miley attributed their
bad relationship to her own insecurities
when the show began Emily had a much
more impressive resume than Miley did
they tried to be friends but always
ended up on each other's throats they
starred on the show together for two
years before filming the Hannah Montana
movie there they shared a totally
sentimental moment over some baby birds
found in the shed then they started to
put aside their differences and
eventually became really close in 2012
Miley said that they loved each other
like sisters but that they had a really
bumpy start we're just glad their issues
didn't show up on the show Bella Thorne
swimsuits Disney has some pretty strict
guidelines for their stars and some of
those guidelines have to do with their
behavior outside of the set Bella Thorne
star of Disney Channel's shake it up was
nearly fired when she was just 14 why
because she wore a bikini swimsuit Bella
was caught by the paparazzi wearing a
black bikini with lace most people
thought it was super cute including
Bella's mom who bought it for her but
Disney Channel disagreed they thought it
was just too revealing and inappropriate
they threatened to fire her over it
thankfully Bella Thorne was so popular
that they couldn't afford to lose her
fan base but they warned her that if she
messed up again she would be without a
job can you imagine having that amount
of pressure put on you as a teenager and
we're pretty sure any kid who has been
to a beach or a swimming pool has seen
way more revealing swimsuits
honestly we're glad Bella stuck it out
and didn't get fired because where would
we be without shake it up we're happy
Bella has totally found
excessed outside of Disney Channel and
can now wear whatever swimsuit she wants
the Jonas Brothers if it weren't for the
Disney Channel the world would probably
have never heard of the Jonas Brothers
the pop band consisting of three
brothers Nick's Joe and Kevin got their
big break by guest starring on Hannah
Montana after they became super popular
on Camp Rock Disney Channel gave them
their own show but even though they know
Disney gave them their fame the Jonas
Brothers especially Joe have criticized
Disney several times both brothers have
talked about how embarrassing Camp Rock
was and Joe released a towel in 2013 he
said that Jonas had terrible writing he
was uncomfortable having to act like a
16 year old when he was 20 he couldn't
even have a kissing scene and Disney
totally took advantage of the purity
ring's story forcing them to change
lyrics if they didn't vibe with the
wholesome vibe Disney was trying to sell
they really felt like they didn't have
any creative freedom Joe had gone so far
as to say being part of Disney was like
being a perfect little puppet Nick is
glad to have creative freedom now but
he's been less outspoken since his
brother regardless of any bad
experiences Disney definitely gave the
Jonas Brothers a huge fan base that
followed them into their solo careers
breaking the mold being a Disney Channel
star comes with a certain image that
they have to maintain and while they get
a lot of Fame they also get stuck with
the Disney label it can be really
difficult for Disney Channel stars to
find other work in Hollywood Hilary
Duff's star of the classic show Lizzie
McGuire said it was four or five years
before people started seeing her as
something other than Lizzie in 2015
Selena Gomez said it was difficult to
get people to accept her as more than
just a good little girl Vanessa Hudgens
is thankful for her time at Disney but
has said her time they're really close
people's minds to seeing her as a more
serious actress even heartthrob Zac
Efron says he sometimes feels like
nothing more than that kid from high
school musical
and in a 20-17 interview dylan sprouse
from sweet life says how hurtful the
insult former child star can be all
these actors are so much more than that
overall they are grateful for the
opportunity but also glad they left a
disney behind it must be terrifying to
leave not knowing if you can have
success without disney channel that
disney is really great at picking super
talented actors so it's no surprise that
many of them have gone
to have awesome careers casting drama
that so raven was a pretty important
show for the Disney Channel it was the
first to focus on a black family it was
the first to get more than 65 episodes
and it was just really funny the
characters had great chemistry but the
show could have been way different
Raven actually auditioned for the role
of the best friend but she was so great
in her audition they gave her the title
role and they changed the character's
name can you imagine if the show had
been about a psychic teen named Don
while that isn't exactly a dark secret
how Annalise Vander pol got the job
isn't quite so light-hearted
the role for Chelsea was already cast by
another girl but Raven convinced the
producers to give the role to her
friends and Elise which put the other
girl out of work we sure hope whoever
that girl was went on to greatness
honestly we are super glad Annalise got
the role we can't imagine anyone else
being Ravens goofy devoted bestie it
still seems a little shady but we all
know success in Hollywood is all about
who you know Disney Channel is no
different there's no doubt that sir
Raven would have been a totally
unrecognizable show if the casting
decisions were different that's so
criminal speaking of that so Raven and
Elise Vanderpool wasn't quite the
innocent girl her character was in July
2006 wow that's so raven was still on
the air
Vanderpol was arrested for driving while
intoxicated her blood-alcohol level was
more than twice the legal limit she hit
a parked car which then hit two other
cars then she lost control of the car
and hit another one luckily no one was
injured she was charged with two
misdemeanors and sentenced to 36 months
of probation she also had to pay a
couple of thousand dollars in fees and
take an alcohol education class even
though we love Annalise we are glad she
had some consequences
she finished out her role as Chelsea on
the show which ended in 2007 even Disney
stars can make terrible mistakes and
she's not the only friend of Raven who
made a terrible decision
Orlando Brown was arrested in 2016 for
hitting his girlfriend he was arrested
again in 2018 for outstanding warrants
Oh Eddie what have you done I think
that's bad wait till you find out which
Disney Channel star committed a crime so
bad he served two jail time body image
issues Miley Cyrus was just a loving
when she became the star of Hannah
Montana the show was super popular and
she became a celebrity practically
overnight
we've
told you about my lease onset drama but
she's also very candid about how the
role affected her personally every day
Miley was forced into a blonde wig and a
ton of makeup and she played a
sixteen-year-old Miley has said it has
really messed with her body image even
giving her a bit of body dysmorphia
that's where a person becomes obsessed
with the flaw on their body that may not
even really be there she was told what a
girl is supposed to be like and she had
a hard time figuring out who she really
is
she's definitely no longer like Hannah
Montana she's successful and
controversial and outspoken she
criticizes Hollywood's definition of
perfect and says she still struggles
with looking at Instagram wondering why
she doesn't look like some of those
models but we all know a lot of those
photos are enhanced being photoshopped
and made up from a young age could
seriously take a toll on someone
we hope Miley has a lot less issues with
body image than before a ton of
spaghetti there's no doubt that
spaghetti is delicious but did you know
that it can be dangerous well if a whole
bunch of it gets dumped on your head it
can even Stevens was a super popular
show starring Shia LaBeouf and Christy
Carlson Romano in the early 2000s one of
the leading antagonists coach Doug Nutt
was played by actor Jim wise coach Doug
Nutt loved Louis's older brother Donnie
but did not care for Luis Luis Stephens
antics with strict coach Doug nut were
some of the funniest scenes in the Even
Stevens movie tag nut gets a ton of
spaghetti dumped on him like a lot of
spaghetti and you would think that
spaghetti is pretty soft food and it
wouldn't hurt wrong they probably should
have hired a stunt double or given him a
helmet
Jim Weiss said it hurts so bad he had to
stand on a chair under a scaffold where
two guys had two large bins full of
spaghetti the impact of the spaghetti
and the compression from the top of his
head through his neck caused him to
nearly black out he was literally seen
stars from the hit yikes we think we
will just stick to eating spaghetti
instead demi lovato spirals out of
control
in 2010 demi lovato star of disney
channel's sunny with the chance made
national headlines she was on tour with
the Jonas Brothers for camp Rock - and
she punched a backup dancer apparently
Demi was upset from getting in trouble
the night before she walked up to Alex
Welch on the airplane and punched her in
the face Alex suffered a black eye and a
bruised cheek but no
damage but the dancer felt hurt because
she thought that they were friends
Dimmie was fired from the tour she ain't
a treatment for substance abuse cutting
and an eating disorder
what demi did was wrong of course but
she was also struggling with some really
dark issues her depression was bad and
her family and her manager got her into
a rehabilitation program in Illinois for
three months Jimmy did not return to
sunny with a chance but has become a
successful musician outside of Disney we
are so glad she got help because that is
a lot for an 18 year old girl to deal
with and we sure hope she and Alex made
amends Demi Lovato has become very
outspoken about mental health and
getting help to fight those inner demons
mr. Mosby's criminal record
you probably remember mr. Moseby from
The Suite Life of Zack and Cody and at
the suite life on deck mr. Moseby played
by Phil Lewis was the no-nonsense
manager of the hotel and later a
chaperone on the cruise ship he was a
hilarious character and really helps
make the show successful but the actor
has a dark past in December of 1991 Phil
Lewis was drinking and driving in
Maryland he caused a wreck that led to
the death of a 21 year old woman when he
was arrested his blood alcohol level was
three times the legal limit he was
charged with vehicular manslaughter and
found guilty Phil Lewis served a full
year in jail and he also served two
years of probation and completed 350
hours of community service we know some
Disney stars grow up to have been caught
under the influence but who knew Disney
would hire someone with manslaughter on
their record we sure hope the victim's
family is doing okay we're glad Phil
Lewis didn't just get away with it but
we're also glad he kept acting because
mr. Moseby is just too funny which of
these secrets is the most shocking let
us know in the comments and those are
the 10 dark secrets Disney Channel has
been hiding your whole childhood be sure
to like this video and subscribe for
more amazing content see you next time
[Music]